thank you very kind of you
thank you for being here and uh a
special welcome
[Music]
a special welcome to all the ladies
fleeing texas you're welcome here in our
state
well you heard about that [ __ ] wow but
they really went full hog there in texas
abortions now now banned if a woman is
more than six weeks pregnant
six weeks wow i mean they say
everything's bigger in texas
not fetuses
[Applause]
i mean six weeks most women don't even
know if they're pregnant at that point
or if they really ever want to see the
guy again
i bought a car last year they gave me
more time to see if i wanted to keep the
satellite radio
and
this bill is serious this bill
encourages citizen bounty hunters did
you see that part of it oh my god to sue
anyone
a stranger who who you see assisting a
woman getting an abortion it's it's
called the riches for snitches program
and the way it works is there a website
and you can be the whistleblower and
this is again anyone who assists a woman
this would be the uber driver
probably will be the uber driver but i
want to say parenthetically if you're
making your girlfriend take an uber to
an abortion
maybe you're an even bigger [ __ ]
i don't know
but
in other medieval governments news
the taliban over in afghanistan they
announced that the kabul airport is
getting back to normal isn't that a good
thing uh several uh flights went off a
hundred hundreds of foreigners including
americans have taken off out of
commercial flights etiquette and look
i'm not a fan of the taliban i don't
care who knows it
but i got to say the taliban when they
tell people and coach to wait until
business class is boarded they wait
oh also
the
the last jew has left afghanistan
the only jew
there was one jew and he has now left
and he said it was tough to be a jew the
only jew
in afghanistan but on the bright side
never await when he ordered chinese food
that's so there's always a bright side
and uh
but here the other big news of course
you saw today i see you're all messed up
biden has ordered sweeping uh federal
vaccine requirements now mandates for a
private and sector employees
health care workers federal contractors
republicans pushing back
in texas governor roberts said it is no
fair
if you fire people to make them do what
you want how can i sue them to make them
do what i want
that's right
ah
i love that thinking into applause
it's a new one
i like that but uh it's also the 20th
anniversary i'm sure you know tomorrow
of 9 11 or as gen z calls it what
yeah that was before they were born they
don't know they don't care they believe
they have their own 911 which is the day
kim kardashian's ass broke the internet
that's they're not going away
uh
and of course uh california's big recall
are you excited about this are you
trepidatious about this is the ending
tuesday have you mailed in ballots we've
been doing that for a while
oh i tell you
california politics is so confusing i
opened the ballot and it was just that
newsome's name and then [ __ ] marry or
kill what
that can't be
and he's running
his big contender is uh larry elder uh
you know larry elder african-american uh
conservative radio host uh i i i larry
used to do our show right where who
who's working with me uh
we should have larry on again after he
loses
anyway uh
i like larry
but
but larry no i like he he's not afraid
to put it out there he said on on
reparations the subject came up in an
interview and he said you could argue
that slave owners
because slaves were property at the time
they could get reparations
the owners
yes you could argue that larry if you
want to get your ass kicked at the
barber that that's what i would
wow
harry's out there oh and finally
congratulations to our transportation
secretary and his husband pete
butterjudge remember pete ran for
president
uh his husband chaston they uh
they had a baby another two they had
twins and you know i must say such a
high-profile uh birth drove home the
point that gay people have children for
the exact same reason that straight
couples do they have run out of things
to talk about
you